wir sprechen auch noch über jemand
anderen und der ist bekannt geworden mit
einem satz der beschreibt dass er super
abend hatte wir haben noch mal rein
die könnten sich jetzt anschickt habe
dass ich entspannt bin uns nach vorne ja
das ist unser
brummi brian den millionen zuschauer
mittlerweile in deutschland kennen vor
allen dingen wegen dieses satzes den er
gesagt hat in seinem lkw unterwegs in
seinem dienst aber wir lernen ihn besser
kennen die frau natürlich auf einer ganz
anderen ebene mal kennenlernen denn
bryan weiß ja offenbar wie es geht muss
man sagen hat also ein gespür für
beziehungen oder die liebe man weiß es
nicht ganz klar aber unsere reporterin
alina bayer die hat sich pünktlich zum
valentinstag ein paar tipps von brein
geholt und wollte natürlich ganz genau
wissen wie läuft eigentlich bei ihm die
beziehung so ab denn das ist ja die
frage die sich millionen deutsche ist
auch stellen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
darf ich sie dir gerne
das ist mein erster verein gentleman
macht immer die tür auf
wie lange bis du meiner freundin
zusammen ja fast zwei jahre bin ich
jetzt mit ihm zusammen
was auf jeden fall wir hätten die
hormone so hoffentlich meine fans von
mir selber sondern anfangen die
endorphine sprießen gramm zu 100
irgendwann der höhenflug leistung die
für
nader lässt momentan nicht so wirklich
nach weil wir uns sein geheimnis man
sieht sich erstmal nicht so oft das ist
das große geheimnis
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich zwei
aufmerksamkeit in berlin eine
überraschung
so da bin ich wieder
[Musik]
auch mit vielen dank so du hattest
zucker vorher gemerkt super danke
aufmerksamkeiten so hatte sich das nun
überraschend nicht
[Musik]
wir sind aber nicht nur die
zwanziger tankstellen blumen aber
schatzi kriegs nachher schöne routen
[Musik]
jede frau ist anders die eine magd den
humor die andere ist sehr schüchtern und
die andere ist halt auch sehr oft
dringlich man will ja als mann erobern
man sie ja nicht gleich
ans fleisch kann
[Musik]
so alina wir sind angekommen was sie
spaß gemacht finden ist und ich mich
jetzt in dem moment wollte ich in
österreich
bis 12
ja
[Musik]
da ist erdigen romantiker der bryan ganz
andere seite die wir da von ihm sehen
oder ja ist das so ja also mit blumen
und so weiß ich habe seine freundin
gemeinsam das hat man sich immer gefragt
oder wie lange sind sie schon zusammen
zwei jahren sind die zellen und das
scheint ja gut zu funktionieren
hauptsache ist sie lag bei denen das ist
unsere chefin janina kirsch und von ihr
wollen wir natürlich wissen der bryan
wie siehst du denn der ist kult geworden
millionen menschen wenn sich dieses
video angeschaut sag mal ist sehen wir
den es bei euch öfter im ressort trat
potenzial ganz oben angesiedelt er hat
auf jeden fall starpotenzial denn er ist
ein typ ist ein charakter und heute muss
man sehr sagen durch social media hat
sich diese ganze star sache ja auch ein
bisschen verändert also du brauchst
nicht mehr ein
riesengroßes talent so wie damals
irgendwie ein super schauspieler sein
oder ein super musiker sondern du wirst
mussten aber sein ein charakter sein die
leute wollen sich mit ihr identifizieren
sowie jungs zum beispiel viele pablo
wird der ja den das dschungelcamp
gewonnen hat das ist auch so eine type
ehrlich spricht vom herzen heraus und
genau diese züge hat halt auch unser
brian und deswegen hat er auf jeden fall
potenzial
er ist so ein typ der von der masse
gefeiert wird weil er halt dazu gehöre
gehört er kommt daher und ja jetzt fehlt
aber noch so ein bisschen würde ich
sagen so der letzte kniff und der letzte
weg um dann wirklich ganz ganz groß zu
werden es klingt so als hätte janine
eine idee wir holen aber erstmal brian
dazu dann kann sie ihn ja vielleicht
auch ein paar tipps geben wir haben ja
so tolle romantische rote schon von ihm
bekommen brian schönes
happy valentine's day was geht er ja
besonders ans herz wenn wir gerade
gesehen aber es gibt ein gutes gefühl
schon wenn man brian lachen sieht
einfach nur da ist irgendwie die welt in
ordnung ich glaube die sonne hat bis
eben nicht geschehen ab jetzt ist
frühling es ist frühling hier im studio
danke das nehmen wir auch gar nicht sein
also bei das eigene starpotenzial ich
weiß ich hab das gehört als janina er
schätzt es als recht hoch ein wie ist es
für dich das als profi zu hören und sag
mal du kannst auch nicht ins detail
gehen aber für ein valentinstag ist
jetzt alles schon auch richtig was
vorbereitet für deine freundin oder
ja ja aber das habe ich gleich verraten
das ist keine überraschung mehr da haben
wir nämlich mit der überraschung aber so
viel kann ich sagen blumen sind auf
jeden fall dabei und noch eine
kleinigkeit worauf sie gar nicht kommt
dann in einem studio ich leide nicht
vielleicht kommt er doch drauf naja das
war ja heute valentinstag ist hast du
nicht nur du eine überraschung für deine
freundin sondern wir haben auch eine
überraschung für dich und diese
überraschung hat mit aber nicht mit
einer frau zu tun sondern mit einem mann
und dieser mann ja der ist so die größte
nummer die es in der musikszene vor
allen dingen in der auf mallorca gibt
über 300 veröffentlichte songs
1,6 milliarden mal wurden diese
gestreamt auf spotify und er hat schon
für einige große gearbeitet mir julia
lorenz büffel sagt die saison
die rede ist ist man hier die rede ist
von diesem mann ihr
liebe bildseite riesige stuhl und ich
hab mal gesehen aufgestockt
der general habe klopp der promi bleiben
hat mark dampf abgelassen erst dazu vor
regenschirm mit seiner freundin
also was gehabt und dann gehupt ohne
ende jetzt weiß ich aber den jugend
wollen seiner freunde weil ich den tag
davor in spielwaren oder wegen der klima
aktivisten auf ihn weil der typ ist
erkannte braten liter die promi bryan am
ballermann da sehe ich die aber ich habe
keine handynummer könnt ihr den kontakt
zu promi kein hersteller macht die kohle
gold in kleinen song über zum beispiel
die hupen seiner freundin open gegen den
klimawandel oder einfach nur
so bleiben lastet von vollkommen aus die
zu machen aber
er bleibt was sagst du dazu wisse dabei
breit golffahrer man
zusammen mit egal schreibt
econ ecke
schätzt auf jeden fall ich bin
überrascht ich bin überwältigt ja ich
weiß gar nichts dazu sagen so es ist
schon überraschend schon lange nicht
mehr bekommen ja dann würde ich sagen
wolltest du mal ein bisschen zu hause
dich jetzt internet nicht nur unter der
dusche vorbereiten mit dem singen
sondern vielleicht auch über ein
bisschen bisschen loslegen hier zu
trällern singen doch mal was für und
fand sie dann singen spielen eigentlich
nicht so eine riesenrolle glaube ich am
ballermann aber vielleicht die basics
spontan wenn wenn der beat kommt dann
gibt es
im refrain wir machen uns keine angst
dass durch das ist ein zusätzlicher
durch also wir werden dich auf jeden
fall ich bin mir ganz ganz sicher
demnächst im bierkönig sehen oder im
megapark das wird richtig groß bryant
ich verspreche dir
ich freue mich wie romy brian